is there a particular security
vulnerability that worries you the most
that you think about the most in terms
of it being a really hard problem and a
really important problem self so it's
very interesting and so I have in the
past have worked essentially through the
Oh through the different stacks in the
systems and I can networking security
software security and even in staffing
security there is our time program
binary security and then web security
mobile security so so throughout we have
been developing more techniques and
tools to improve security of these
software systems and as a consequence
actually is a very interesting thing
that we are seeing an interesting trends
that we are seeing is that the attacks
are actually moving more anymore from
the systems South yeah two ways to
humans so it's moving up the stack it's
a movie after stack that's faster and
also it's moving more and more towards
what we call the weakest link so we say
though in security we say the weakest
link actually have the system's
oftentimes is actually humans themselves
so a lot of attacks for example that I
could is through social engineering are
from these other methods they actually
attack the humans and then attack the
systems so we'll actually have projects
that actually works on how to use a
machine learning to help humans to
defend against this type of attack so
yeah so if we look at humans as security
vulnerabilities is their is their
methods is that what you're kind of
referring to is there hope or
methodology for patching the humans I
think in the future this is going to be
really more of a serious issue because
again for for machines for systems we
can yes we can patch them we can build
more secure systems we can harden them
as well but humans are actually we don't
have a way to say to a software upgrade
out to a hardware change for humans and
so for example right now we you know we
already see different types of attacks
in particularly I think in the future
they
are going to be even more effective on
humans so as I mentioned social
engineering attacks like these phishing
attacks attack us I just get humans to
provide their passwords and there have
been instances where even places like
Google and other places and that's
supposed to have really good security
people there have been fished to
actually wire money to attackers and
also we talked about this the fake and
fake news to these essentially are there
to target humans to manipulate humans
opinions perceptions and so on and so I
think in going to the future these are
going to become more and more severe
users for their of the stack yes yes so
so you see kind of social engineering
automated social engineering as a kind
of security vulnerability oh absolutely
and again given that the humans are the
weakest link to the system I I would say
this is the type of attacks that I would
be most worried about oh that's
fascinating okay so that's also we need
to a I to help humans to as I mentioned
we have some projects in the space
actually helps and that can you maybe
can go there for the GS what are some
ideas projects we are working on is
actually using an LP and chatbot
techniques to help humans for example
the chat pod actually could be they're
observing the conversation between a
user and remote correspondence and then
the chap out could be there to try to
observe to see whether the
correspondence is potentially attacker
for example in some of the phishing
attacks the attacker claims to be a
relative of the user and the and the
relative got lost in London and he's you
know Wally's have been stolen had no
money as the user to wire money to send
money to the attacker and to the
correspondence and so then in this case
the Chabad actually could try to
nice and there may be something
suspicious going on this relates to
asking money to be sent and also the
chibok could actually pose and we call
it challenge and response the
correspondence claims to be a relative
of the user then the checkout could
automatically actually generate some
kind of challenges to see whether the
correspondence knows the appropriate
knowledge to prove that he actually else
he or she actually is the claimed
relative after user and so in the future
I think these type of technologies
actually could help protect users that's
funny so get the so chat but that's kind
of focused for looking for the kind of
patterns they're usually usually
associated with social engineering
attacks right it would be able to then
test sort of do a basic capture type of
a response to see is this is the faction
of the semantics of the claims you're
making true right develop you know more
powerful and now P and T bar techniques
the chapel could even engage further
conversations with the correspondence to
for example if it turns out to be a and
you know attack then the the the traffic
can try to engage in conversations with
the attacker to try to learn more
information from the attacker as well so
it's a very interesting area so that
chap I is essentially your your little
representative in the spate in the
security space it's like your little
lawyer that protects you from doing
anything stupid that's a fascinating
vision for the future do you see that
broadly applicable across the web so you
across all your interactions
what about like on social networks for
example so across all of that do you see
that being implemented in sort of that's
a service that a company would provide
or does every single social network has
to implement it themselves so Facebook
and Twitter and so on or do you see
there being like a security service that
kinda is a plug-and-play that's a very
good question I think
of course we still have a ways to go
until the a now P and the chat
techniques can be that effective but I
think it right once it's powerful enough
I do see that that can be a service at a
user can employee or can be deployed by
the platforms it's just the curious side
to me on security and we'll talk about
privacy is who gets a little bit more of
the control who gets to you know on
whose side is the representative is it
on face book side that there is the
security protector or is it on your side
and it has different implications about
how much that little chatbot security
protector knows about you right exactly
if you have a little security bot that
you carry with you everywhere from
Facebook to Twitter to all your services
they might it might know a lot more
about you and a lot more about your
relatives to be able to test those
things but that's okay because you have
more control of that as opposed to
Facebook having that that's a really
interesting trade-off
you